The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer
high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare at
OCW.mit.edu.
Recall that yesterday we saw,
no, two days ago we learned
about the curl of a vector field
in space.
And we said the curl of F is
defined by taking a cross
product between the symbol dell
and the vector F.
Concretely, the way we would
compute this would be by putting
the components of F into this
determinant and expanding and
then getting a vector with
components Ry minus Qz,
Pz minus Rx and Qx minus Py.
I think I also tried to explain
very quickly what the
significance of a curl is.
Just to tell you again very
quickly,
basically curl measures,
if you mention that your vector
field measures the velocity in
some fluid then the curl
measures how much rotation is
taking place in that fluid.
Measures the rotation part of a
velocity field.
More precisely the direction
corresponds to the axis of
rotation and the magnitude
corresponds to twice the angular
velocity.
Just to give you a few quick
examples.
If I take a constant vector
field,
so everything translates at the
same speed,
then obviously when you take
the partial derivatives you will
just get a bunch of zeros so the
curl will be zero.
If you take a vector field that
stretches things,
let's say, for example,
we are going to stretch things
along the x-axis,
that would be a vector field
that goes parallel to the x
direction but maybe,
say, x times i.
So that when you are in front
of a plane of a blackboard you
are moving forward,
when you are behind you are
moving backwards,
things are getting expanded in
the x direction.
If you compute the curl,
you can check each of these.
Again, they are going to be
zero.
There is no curl.
This is not what curl measures.
I mean, actually,
what measures expansion,
stretching is actually
divergence.
If you take the divergence of
this field,
you would get one plus zero
plus zero,
it looks like it will be one,
so in case you don't remember,
I mean divergence precisely
measures this stretching effect
in your field.
And, on the other hand,
if you take something that
corresponds to,
say,
rotation about the z-axis at
unit angular velocity -- That
means they are going to moving
in circles around the z-axis.
One way to write down this
field, let's see,
the z component is zero because
everything is moving
horizontally.
And in the x and y directions,
if you look at it from above,
well, it is just going to be
our good old friend the vector
field that rotates everything
[at unit speed?].
And we have seen the formula
for this one many times.
The first component is minus y,
the second one is x.
Now, if you compute the curl of
this guy, you will get zero,
zero, two, two k.
And so k is the axis of
rotation, two is twice the
angular velocity.
And now, of course,
you can imagine much more
complicated motions where you
will have -- For example,
if you look at the Charles
River very carefully then you
will see that water is flowing,
generally speaking,
towards the ocean.
But, at the same time,
there are actually a few eddies
in there and with water
swirling.
Those are the places where
there is actually curl in the
flow.
Yes.
I don't know how to turn out
the lights a bit,
but I'm sure there is a way.
Does this do it?
Is it working?
OK.
You're welcome.
Hopefully it is easier to see
now.
That was about curl.
Now, why do we care about curl
besides this motivation of
understanding motions?
One place where it comes up is
when we try to understand
whether a vector field is
conservative.
Remember we have seen that a
vector field is conservative if
and only if its curl is zero.
That is the situation in which
we are allowed to try to look
for a potential function and
then use the fundamental
theorem.
But another place where this
comes up,
if you remember what we did in
the plane,
curl also came up when we tried
to convert nine integrals into
double integrals.
That was Greene's theorem.
Well, it turns out we can do
the same thing in space and that
is called Stokes' theorem.
What does Stokes' theorem say?
It says that the work done by a
vector field along a closed
curve can be replaced by a
double integral of curl F.
Let me write it using the dell
notation.
That is curl F.
Dot ndS on a suitably chosen
surface.
That is a very strange kind of
statement.
But actually it is not much
more strange than things we have
seen before.
I should clarify what this
means.
C has to be a closed curve in
space.
And S can be any surface
bounded by C.
For example,
what Stokes' theorem tells me
is that let us say that I have
to compute some line integral on
maybe,
say, the unit circle in the x,
y plane.
Of course I can set a line
integral directly and compute it
by setting x equals cosine T,
y equals sine T,
z equals zero.
But maybe sometimes I don't
want to do that because my
vector field is really
complicated.
And instead I will want to
reduce things to a surface
integral.
Now, I know that you guys are
not necessarily fond of
computing flux of vector fields
for surfaces so maybe you don't
really see the point.
But sometimes it is useful.
Sometimes it is also useful
backwards because,
actually, you have a surface
integral that you would like to
turn into a line integral.
What Stokes' theorem says is
that I can choose my favorite
surface whose boundary is this
circle.
I could choose,
for example,
a half sphere if I want or I
can choose, let's call that s1,
I don't know,
a pointy thing,
s2.
Probably the most logical one,
actually, would be just to
choose a disk in the x,
y plane.
That would probably be the
easiest one to set up for
calculating flux.
Anyway,
what Stokes' theorem tells me
is I can choose any of these
surfaces,
whichever one I want,
and I can compute the flux of
curl F through this surface.
Curl F is a new vector field
when you have this formula that
gives you a vector field you
compute its flux through your
favorite surface,
and you should get the same
thing as if you had done the
line integral for F.
That is the statement.
Now, there is a catch here.
What is the catch?
Well, the catch is we have to
figure out what conventions to
use because remember when we
have a surface there are two
possible orientations.
We have to decide which way we
will counter flux positively,
which way we will counter flux
negatively.
And, if we change our choice,
then of course the flux will
become the opposite.
Well, similarly to define the
work, I need to choose which way
I am going to run my curve.
If I change which way I go
around the curve then my work
will become the opposite.
What happens is I have to
orient the curve C and the
surface S in compatible ways.
We have to figure out what the
rule is for how the orientation
of S and that of C relate to
each other.
What about orientation?
Well, we need the orientations
of C and S to be compatible and
they have to explain to you what
the rule is.
Let me show you a picture.
The rule is if I walk along C
with S to my left then the
normal vector is pointing up for
me.
Let me write that.
If I walk along C,
I should say in the positive
direction, in the direction that
I have chosen to orient C.
With S to my left then n is
pointing up for me.
Here is the example.
If I am walking on this curve,
it looks like the surface is to
my left.
And so the normal vector is
going towards what is up for me.
Any questions about that?
I see some people using their
right hands.
That is also right-handable
which I am going to say in just
a few moments.
That is another way to remember
this.
Before I tell you about the
right-handable version,
let me just try something.
Actually, I am not happy with
this orientation of C and I want
to orient my curve C going
clockwise on the picture.
So the other orientation.
Then, if I walk on it this way,
the surface would be to my
right.
You can remember,
if it helps you,
that if a surface is to your
right then the normal vector
will go down.
The other way to think about
this rule is enough because if
you are walking clockwise,
well, you can change that to
counterclockwise just by walking
upside down.
This guy is walking clockwise
on C.
And while for him,
if you look carefully at the
picture, the surface is actually
to his left when you flip upside
down.
Yeah, it is kind of confusing.
But, anyway,
maybe it's easier if you
actually rotate in the picture.
And now it is getting actually
really confusing because his
walking upside up with,
actually, the surface is to his
left.
I mean where he is at here is
actually at the front and this
is the back, but that is kind of
hard to see.
Anyway, whichever method will
work best for you.
Perhaps it is easiest to first
do it with the other
orientation,
this one,
and this side,
if you want the opposite one,
then you will just flip
everything.
Now, what is the other way of
remembering this with the
right-hand rule?
First of all,
take your right hand,
not your left.
Even if your right hand is
actually using a pen or
something like that in your
right hand do this.
And let's take your fingers in
order.
First your thumb.
Let's make your thumb go along
the object that has only one
dimension in there.
That is the curve.
Well, let's look at the top
picture up there.
I want my thumb to go along the
curve so that is kind of towards
the right.
Then I want to make my index
finger point towards the
surface.
Towards the surface I mean
towards the interior of the
surface from the curve.
And when I am on the curve I am
on the boundary of the surface,
so there is a direction along
the surface that is the curve
and the other one is pointing
into the surface.
That one would be pointing kind
of to the back slightly up
maybe, so like that.
And now your middle finger is
going to point in the direction
of the normal vector.
That is up, at least if you
have the same kind of right hand
as I do.
The other way of doing it is
using the right-hand rule along
C positively.
The index finger towards the
interior of S.
Sorry, I shouldn't say interior.
I should say tangent to S
towards the interior of S.
What I mean by that is really
the part of S that is not its
boundary, so the rest of the
surface.
Then the middle finger points
parallel to n.
Let's practice.
Let's say that I gave you this
curve bounding this surface.
Which way do you think the
normal vector will be going?
Up. Yes. Everyone is voting up.
Imaging that I am walking
around C.
That is to my left.
Normal vector points up.
Imagine that you put your thumb
along C, your index towards S
and then your middle finger
points up.
Very good.
N points up.
Another one.
It is interesting to watch you
guys.
I think mostly it is going up.
The correct answer is it goes
up and into the cone.
How do we see that?
Well, one way to think about it
is imagine that you are walking
on C, on the rim of this cone.
You have two options.
Imagine that you are walking
kind of inside or imagine that
you are walking kind of outside.
If you are walking outside then
S is to your right,
but it does not sound good.
Let's say instead that you are
walking on the inside of a cone
following the boundary.
Well, then the surface is to
your left.
And so the normal vector will
be up for you which means it
will be pointing slightly up and
into the cone.
Another way to think about it,
through the right-hand rule,
from this way index going kind
of down because the surface goes
down and a bit to the back.
And then the normal vector
points up and in.
Yet another way,
if you deform continuously your
surface then the conventions
will not change.
See, this is kind of
topology
in a way.
You can deform things and
nothing will change.
So what if we somehow flatten
our cone, push it a bit up so
that it becomes completely flat?
Then, if you had a flat disk
with the curve going
counterclockwise,
the normal vector would go up.
Now take your disk with its
normal vector sticking up.
If you want to paint the face a
different color so that you can
remember that was beside with a
normal vector and then push it
back down to the cone,
you will see that the painted
face,
the one with the normal vector
on that side is the one that is
inside and up.
Does that make sense?
Anyway, I think you have just
to play with these examples for
long enough and get it.
OK. The last one.
Let's say that I have a
cylinder.
So now this guy has actually
two boundary curves,
C and C prime.
And let's say I want to orient
my cylinder so that the normal
vector sticks out.
How should I choose the
orientation of my curves?
Let's start with,
say, the bottom one.
Would the bottom one be going
clockwise or counterclockwise.
Most people seem to say
counterclockwise,
and I agree with that.
Let me write that down and
claim C prime should go
counterclockwise.
One way to think about it,
actually, it's quite easy,
you mentioned that you're
walking on the outside of the
cylinder along C prime.
If you want to walk along C
prime so that the cylinder is to
your left, that means you have
to actually go counterclockwise
around it.
The other way is use your right
hand.
Say when you're at the front of
C prime,
your thumb points to the right,
your index points up because
that's where the surface is,
and then your middle finger
will point out.
What about C?
Well, C I claim we should be
doing clockwise.
I mean think about just walking
again on the surface of the
cylinder along C.
If you walk clockwise,
you will see that the surface
is to your left or use the
right-hand rule.
Now, if a problem gives you
neither the orientation of a
curve nor that of the surface
then it's up to you to make them
up.
But you have to make them up in
a consistent way.
You cannot choose them both at
random.
All right.
Now we're all set to try to use
Stokes' theorem.
Well, let me do an example
first.
The first example that I will
do is actually a comparison.
Stokes' versus Green.
I want to show you how Green's
theorem for work that we saw in
the plane,
but also involved work and curl
and so on,
is actually a special case of
this.
Let's say that we will look at
the special case where our curve
C is actually a curve in the x,
y plane.
And let's make it go
counterclockwise in the x,
y plane because that's what we
did for Green's theorem.
Now let's choose a surface
bounded by this curve.
Well, as I said,
I could make up any surface
that comes to my mind.
But, if I want to relate to
this stuff, I should probably
stay in the x,
y plane.
So I am just going to take my
surface to be the piece of the
x, y plane that is inside my
curve.
So let's say S is going to be a
portion of x,
y plane bounded by a curve C,
and the curve C goes
counterclockwise.
Well, then I should look at
[the table?].
For work along C of my favorite
vector field F dot dr.
So that will be the line
integral of Pdx plus Qdy.
Like I said,
if I call the components of my
field P, Q and R,
it will be Pdx plus Qdy plus
Rdz, but I don't have any Z
here.
Dz is zero on C.
If I evaluate for line
integral, I don't have any term
involving dz.
Z is zero.
Now, let's see what Strokes
says.
Stokes says instead I can
compute for flux through S of
curve F.
But now what's the normal
vector to my surface?
Well, it's going to be either k
or negative k.
I just have to figure out which
one it is.
Well, if you followed what
we've done there,
you know that the normal vector
compatible with this choice for
the curve C is the one that
points up.
My normal vector is just going
to be k hat, so I am going to
replace my normal vector by k
hat.
That means, actually,
I will be integrating curl dot
k.
That means I am integrating the
z component of curl.
Let's look at curl F dot k.
That's the z component of curl
F.
And what's the z component of
curl?
Well, I conveniently still have
the values up there.
It's Q sub x minus P sub y.
My double integral becomes
double integral of Q sub x minus
P sub y.
What about dS?
Well, I am in a piece of the x,
y plane, so dS is just dxdy or
your favorite combination that
does the same thing.
Now, see, if you look at this
equality, integral of Pdx plus
Qdy along a closed curve equals
double integral of Qx minus Py
dxdy.
That is exactly the statement
of Green's theorem.
I mean except at that time we
called things m and n,
but really that shouldn't
matter.
This tells you that,
in fact, Green's theorem is
just a special case of Stokes'
in the x, y plane.
Now, another small remark I
want to make right away before I
forget,
you might think that these
rules that we've made up about
compatibility of orientations
are completely arbitrary.
Well, they are literally in the
same way as our convention for
which we guy curl is arbitrary.
We chose to make the curl be
this thing and not the opposite
which would have been pretty
much just as sensible.
And, ultimately,
that comes from our choice of
making the cross-product be what
it is but of the opposite.
Ultimately, it all comes from
our preference for right-handed
coordinate systems.
If we had been on the planet
with left-handed coordinate
systems then actually our
conventions would be all the
other way around,
but they are this way.
Any other questions?
A surface that you use in
Stokes' theorem is usually not
going to be closed because its
boundary needs to be the curve
C.
So if you had a closed surface
you wouldn't know where to put
your curve.
I mean of course you could make
a tiny hole in it and get a tiny
curve.
Actually, what that would say,
and we are going to see more
about that so not very important
right now,
but what we would see is that
for a close surface we would end
up getting zero for the flux.
And that is actually because
divergence of curl is zero,
but I am getting ahead of
myself.
We are going to see that
probably tomorrow in more
detail.
Stokes' theorem only works if
you can make sense of this.
That means you need your vector
field to be continuous and
differentiable everywhere on the
surface S.
Now, why is that relevant?
Well, say that your vector
field was not defined at the
origin and say that you wanted
to do,
you know, the example that I
had first with the unit circling
the x, y plane.
Normally, the most sensible
choice of surface to apply
Stokes' theorem to would be just
the flat disk in the x,
y plane.
But that assumes that your
vector field is well-defined
there.
If your vector field is not
defined at the origin but
defined everywhere else you
cannot use this guy,
but maybe you can still use,
say, the half-sphere,
for example.
Or, you could use a piece of
cylinder plus a flat top or
whatever you want but not
pressing for the origin.
So you could still use Stokes
but you'd have to be careful
about which surface you choose.
Now, if instead your vector
field is not defined anywhere on
the z-axis then you're out of
luck because there is no way to
find a surface bounded by this
unit circle without crossing the
z-axis somewhere.
Then you wouldn't be able to
Stokes' theorem at all or at
least not directly.
Maybe I should write it F
defines a differentiable
everywhere on this.
But we don't care about what
happens outside of this.
It's really only on the surface
that we need it to be OK.
I mean, again,
99% of the vector fields that
we see in this class are defined
everywhere so that's not an
urgent concern,
but still.
OK.
Should we move on?
Yes. I have a yes.
Let me explain to you quickly
why Stokes is true.
How do we prove a theorem like
that?
Well,
the strategy,
I mean there are other ways,
but the least painful strategy
at this point is to observe what
we already know is a special
case of Stokes's theorem.
Namely we know the case where
the curve is actually in the x,
y plane and the surface is a
flat piece of the x,
y plane because that's Green's
theorem which we proved a while
ago.
We know it for C and S in the
x, y plane.
Now, what if C and S were,
say, in the y,
z plane instead of the x,
y plane?
Well, then it will not quite
give the same picture because
the normal vector would be i hat
instead of k hat and they would
be having different notations
and it would be integrating with
y and z.
But you see that it would
become, again,
exactly the same formula.
We'd know it for any of the
coordinate planes.
In fact, I claim we know it for
absolutely any plane.
And the reason for that is,
sure, when we write it in
coordinates,
when we write that this line
integral is integral of Pdx plus
Qdy plus Rdz or when we write
that the curl is given by this
formula we use the x,
y, z coordinate system.
But there is something I
haven't quite told you about.
Which is if I switch to any
other right-handed coordinate
system,
so I do some sort of rotation
of my space coordinates,
then somehow the line integral,
the flux integral,
the notion of curl makes sense
in coordinates.
And the reason is that they all
have geometric interpretations.
For example,
when I think of this as the
work done by a force,
well, the force doesn't care
whether it's being put in x,
y coordinates this way or that
way.
It still does the same work
because it's the same force.
And when I say that the curl
measures the rotation in a
motion, well,
that depends on which
coordinates you use.
And the same for interpretation
of flux.
In fact, if I rotated my
coordinates to fit with any
other plane, I could still do
the same things.
What I'm trying to say is,
in fact, if C and S are in any
plane then we can still claim
that it reduces to Green's
theorem.
It will be Green's theorem not
in x, y, z coordinates but in
some funny rotated coordinate
systems.
What I'm saying is that work,
flux and curl makes sense
independently of coordinates.
Now, this has to stop somewhere.
I can start claiming that I can
somehow bend my coordinates to a
plane, any surface is flat.
That doesn't really work.
But what I can say is if I have
any surface I can cut it into
tiny pieces.
And these tiny pieces are
basically flat.
So that's basically the idea of
a proof.
I am going to decompose my
surface into very small flat
pieces.
Given any S we are just going
to decompose it into tiny almost
flat pieces.
For example,
if I have my surface like this,
what I will do is I will just
cut it into tiles.
I mean a good example of that
is if you look at
those geodesic things,
for example,
it's made of all these hexagons
and pentagons.
Well, actually,
they're not quite flat in the
usual rule, but you could make
them flat and it would still
look pretty much like a sphere.
Anyway, you're going to cut
your surface into lots of tiny
pieces.
And then you can use Stokes'
theorem on each small piece.
What it says on each small flat
piece -- It says that the line
integral along say,
for example,
this curve is equal to the flux
of a curl through this tiny
piece of surface.
And now I will add all of these
terms together.
If I add all of the small
contributions to flux I get the
total flux.
What if I add all of the small
line integrals?
Well, I get lots of extra junk
because I never asked to compute
the line integral along this.
But this guy will come in twice
when I do this little plate and
when I do that little plate with
opposite orientations.
When I sum all of the little
line integrals together,
all of the inner things cancel
out,
and the only ones that I go
through only once are those that
are at the outer most edges.
So, when I sum all of my works
together, I will get the work
done just along the outer
boundary C.
Sum of work around each little
piece is just actually the work
along C, the outer curve.
And the sum of the flux for
each piece is going to be the
flux through S.
From Stokes' theorem for flat
surfaces, I can get it for any
surface.
I am cheating a little bit
because you would actually have
to check carefully that this
approximation where you flatten
the little pieces that are
almost flat is varied.
But, trust me,
it actually works.
Let's do an actual example.
I mean I said example,
but that was more like getting
us ready for the proof so
probably that doesn't count as
an actual example.
I should probably keep these
statements for now so I am not
going to erase this side.
Let's do an example.
Let's try to find the work of
vector field zi plus xj plus yk
around the unit circle in the x,
y plane counterclockwise.
The picture is conveniently
already there.
Just as a quick review,
let's see how we do that
directly.
If we do that directly,
I have to find the integral
along C.
So F dot dr becomes zdx plus
xdy plus ydz.
But now we actually know that
on this circle,
well, z is zero.
And we can parameterize x and
y, the unit circle in the x,
y plane, so we can take x
equals cosine t,
y equals sine t.
That will just become the
integral over C.
Well, z times dx,
z is zero so we have nothing,
plus x is cosine t times dy is
-- Well, if y is sine t then dy
is cosine tdt plus ydz but z is
zero.
Now, the range of values for t,
well, we are going
counterclockwise around the
entire circle so that should go
from zero to 2pi.
We will get integral from zero
to 2pi of cosine square tdt
which, if you do the
calculation, turns out to be
just pi.
Now, let's instead try to use
Stokes' theorem to do the
calculation.
Now, of course the smart choice
would be to just take the flat
unit disk.
I am not going to do that.
That would be too boring.
Plus we have already kind of
checked it because we already
trust Green's theorem.
Instead, just to convince you
that,
yes, I can choose really any
surface I want,
let's say that I'm going to
choose a piece of paraboloid z
equals one minus x squared minus
y squared.
Well, to get our conventions
straight, we should take the
normal vector pointing up for
compatibility with our choice.
Well, we will have to compute
the flux through S.
We don't really have to because
we could have chosen the disk,
it would be easier,
but if we want to do it this
way we will compute the flux of
curl F through our paraboloid.
How do we do that?
Well, we need to find the curl
and we need to find ndS.
Let's start with the curl.
Curl F let's take the
cross-product between dell and F
which is zxy.
If we compute this,
the i component will be one
minus zero.
It looks like it is one i.
Minus the j component is zero
minus one.
Plus the k component is one
minus zero.
In fact, the curl of the field
is one, one, one.
Now, what about ndS?
Well, this is a surface for
which we know z is a function of
x and y.
ndS we can write as,
let's call this F of xy,
then we can use the formula
that says ndS equals negative F
sub x, negative F sub y,
one dxdy,
which here gives us 2x,
2y, one dxdy.
Now, when we want to compute
the flux, we will have to do
double integral over S of one,
one, one dot product with 2x,
2y, one dxdy.
It will become the double
integral of 2x plus 2y plus one
dxdy.
And, of course,
the region which we are
integrating, the range of values
of x and y will be the shadow of
our surface.
That is just going to be,
if you look at this paraboloid
from above,
all you will see is the unit
disk so it will be a double
integral of the unit disk.
And the way we will do that,
one way is to switch to polar
coordinates and do the
calculation and then you will
end up with pi.
The other way is to try to do
it by symmetry.
Observe, when you integrate x
above this, x is as negative on
the left as it is positive on
the right.
So the integral of x will be
zero.
The integral of y will be zero
also by symmetry.
Then the integral of one dxdy
will just be the area of this
unit disk which is pi.
That was our first example.
And, of course,
if you're actually free to
choose your favorite surface,
there is absolutely no reason
why you would actually choose
this paraboloid in this example.
I mean it would be much easier
to choose a flat disk.
OK.
Tomorrow I will tell you a few
more things about curl fits in
with conservativeness and with
the divergence theorem,
Stokes all together,
and we will look at Practice
Exam 4B so please bring the exam
with you.